Jimmy and Michael here at CES 2018 we
just checked out the new HTC vive does
it make enough and improvements to get
you into VR let's find out
[Music]
so Michael we just both tried the HTC
vive Pro which is the new headset from
HTC and it features a sharper resolution
with better optics I believe it's like
twenty eight eighty by 1600 P yep
which HTC says is a 78% improvement over
the original vibe we both had a chance
to try it what did you think but I
noticed that you know text is gonna be
sharper on screen and textures are gonna
be a little bit sharper as well or like
at least the edges of objects will look
sharper of course because you know the
high resolution foliage often the
distance also looks a lot crisper they
also said that the minimum specs haven't
changed despite the increase in
resolution like you mentioned when we
were talking about is like that's kind
of hard to believe well the minimum
specs yeah sure but by nature of
increasing the resolution you're
probably gonna want better hardware to
maintain the frame rates yeah yeah I
noticed that like on the original vibe
you know it's it's it's okay but you
have a slight screen during effect and
kind of see pixels a little bit you can
still kind of see the pixels here if
you're looking for but it just looks a
lot you know more clear so they also
change the the ergonomics would you
think about the headsets comfort level I
found it similar to the deluxe strap
that they released last year it's really
easy to put on especially compared to
the original vive setup but they had
like a bunch of straps flying all over
the place so here it's just like loosen
up the dial put it on your head push it
down and then twist dial and then the
strap on top secures it on your head so
they've figured out how to make this
work without people struggling to put
this thing on yeah I think in my opinion
it's similar to Dilek strap it's more
comfortable maybe maybe on par with PSP
yarn that it does a better job at like
weight distribution in the back there is
a dial on the back which makes it easy
to tighten the headset has a new nozzle
so you can like move the head sit
forward backwards more easily as well so
the headset also introduced a new
integrated audio it's kind of similar to
the deluxe but they're slightly
different what did you think about the
audio quality I thought they were
perfectly fine they do what they need to
do I was also impressed with the noise
isolation because like people at HTC
when we're demoing them we're trying to
give me instructions and I had them like
on tight along my ears and I was like
huh what so I couldn't really hear what
their what they're trying to say to me
which is a good thing so yeah you know
see for VR where you want to get
immersed you don't want to hear like
tripping off in the background when
you're like floating in space where they
don't make sense that's nice that you
know not only is it economically more
comfortable but you also get the audio
right there and then with the increase
in resolution you know this is more of a
whole package what do you think that the
head say is for well you know if you
have the HTC vive original and would you
upgrade to this seal I wouldn't see it
as something that original vive owners
want to upgrade to but if you are on the
fence of getting VR I mean you're
definitely gonna want to go with the
vive pro just because of the new
features but at the same time it's not
that big of a job I would say it's more
like a buy of 1.5 then maybe like a web
2.0 or something exactly they also like
showed off the Intel Y gig which allows
the headset to be a wireless you know we
both had a chance to try that playing
Arizona sunshine a zombie you know
killing game what did you think about
that so it's nice to play Wireless VR
without really a backpack strapped to
your head or regular VR where you have a
cord running through the ground you know
your my trip over but I think there's a
very important compromise that you have
to think about is that the visual
quality is very compressed it's very
noticeable right off the bat and I think
that you know it might be a deal-breaker
for me especially going from the vipro
to this wireless device it's a very
noticeable difference in quality yeah
it's almost hard to make out objects
sometimes like that are off in the
distance in VR yeah and this kind of
makes that a little bit harder or
actually a lot harder the thing is going
into Wireless VR I thought about was the
latency that was actually very
impressive you know I went I'm like
looking side to side really fast I
didn't feel any difference between a
wired VR headset in terms of like
tracking my head motion so I think that
is the most important part with wireless
PR and I think they nailed it there
right now the visual quality is another
story
but you definitely notice a compression
I seem to notice it more often within
the distance Oh same and it was almost
to me felt like you're kind of watching
like a 360 p video like watching all of
YouTube you see videos but there's a
trade-off here it's like do you want to
go with a wireless but compress set up
or can you just deal with a wire and
sharper clarity and yeah I agree with
you in terms of like the response time
that's all really good and then that's
sort of compromise that they had to made
between like response time and visual
clarity and I think between those two
you have to go with the response time
yeah because otherwise it will be be
really jittery and you'll get like
can say and that would have been a
deal-breaker right there it's important
to mention that they're still working on
it so it's not out yes along with the
HTC buy pro as well there's no price
release there yet either and then the
last thing they kind of shown off were
the valve lighthouses which allow you to
use four of them to track a bigger area
but again if you just want it for like
regular room scale at home it doesn't
really affect you too much you can just
go with it to standard lighthouse setup
um so yeah that was our impressions of
the HTC vive for more CES coverage head
on over to gamespot.com
thank you for watching
[Music]